اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه
في الولايات المتحده تهديدات بتصفيه
المعارضين الايرانيين في بريطانيا
القتال في سوريا الى جانب النظام
[موسيقى]
الى الحرس الثوري الايراني
واعتباره منظمه ارهابيه لكن اصواتا خرجت
تعارض التصني
بمجموعه من الاسباب ابرزها ان الحرس
الثوري الايراني يضم مجموعات من المجندين
يتم اختيارهم بشكل عشوائي وبالقوه وان
هؤلاء الى خيار لهم سوى اكمال الخدمه
الاجباريه
بوليسيه
لعرقله تصنيف الحرس ارهابيا رغم ان اسباب
التصنيف واضحه ومقنعه وان هذه الحجه تستند
الى فهم خاطئ لاليه التجنيد والصياغه التي
يستخدمها الحرس الثوري الايراني مؤكده ان
المجندين لفتره مؤقته يحصلون على بطاقه
نهايه الخدمه الاجباريه على عكس اعضاء
الحرس يتم
هم للخدمه العسكريه في البلاد هناك فقط
50,000 ينضمون سنويا للحرس الثوري وهؤلاء
يتم تدريبهم على العمل المليشيوي كما
يخضعون للتلقين العقائدي هم وعائلتهم ايضا
وبحسب فرن بوليسيه فان التلقين
الايديولوجيه ركيزه اساسيه لعمل الحرس حيث
يمثل التطرف اكثر من 50% من التدريب في
الحرس الثوري الايراني اليوم
بلال البوجدين العربي